hey guys I have a nasty infection in the
side of my jaw you remember my wisdom
tooth removal surgery about a month ago
well everything was fine and everything
was progressing totally normally but
yesterday I noticed some swelling and
some really intense pain in this side of
my face and I went to the doctor that
did the surgery just yesterday and we
did an x-ray and we looked at it and
apparently well we didn't notice is that
one of the wisdom teeth was eroding the
root of one of the adjacent molars in
this section of my teeth and so what
that did is expose the base of the tooth
for infection so so I took in about
exactly the surgery and this is a month
later and it's kind of a fluke that it
happened but it's really unfortunate
that it did because it's real nasty in
there and I feel awful
like I feel I feel terrible I feel it's
not even like a cold or the flu or
anything I just feel nauseous every time
I like stand up I feel like I'm about to
throw up so I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
incapacitated for a while videos are
obviously not gonna be coming and I'll
keep you guys up to date on on various
things if anything changes but I don't
think anything should they got me on
antibiotics and the antibiotics are
apparently ridiculous there's some real
fun warnings on the side of the bottle
with like you know a drink with plenty
of water don't lay down within ten
minutes of taking the pill you may get
diarrhea from this also you may get
diarrhea
weeks two months after taking the pill
so I have that to look forward to in my
future so just wanna let you guys know
where I'm at I'm fine like it sucks and
it hurts and I feel awful but I'll be
fine
I just need to rest this off it's
unfortunate timing wise because I got a
lot of work that I need to do but you
know I gotta let my I let myself recover
as much as I need to so take care love
you all I'll let you guys know if
anything
and I'll see you in the next one buh-bye
Tata later